milk it's the elixir all mammals feed to
their young deep inside the National Zoo
in Washington DC a team of scientists
are devoted to unlocking the wonders of
the white gold to help animals like baby
Fiona
but more on that later welcome to the
world's largest collection of exotic
animal milk ok let's get to it
meet dr. Michael power can I call you
Mike sure okay Mike what do you do here
I'm the curator of the exotic animal
milk repository at the Smithsonian's
National Zoo
it's the largest by a species count a
number of samples of milk in the entire
world we have samples that have been
collected from all over the world that
we keep in frozen storage animals like
armadillos bats giraffe giant anteater
Asian elephant African lion
cheetahs Tigers sea lions and zebra I
hate to ask but how do you get the milk
well I'll let the Tang show you the Tang
is a critically endangered Bornean
orangutan so this is the classic
collaboration between a scientist and
the animal care staff their incredible
work and effort it be able to training
the animals to be able to accept this
procedure to where they voluntarily
donate samples so now that we know the
how we have to ask why the exotic mammal
milk repository serves two critical
purposes one is basic science that's
simply trying to understand in a sense
the origin of milk and the other is a
very practical pragmatic purpose in the
fact that we have to occasionally
handler animals and therefore we have to
come up with a milk replacer formula
okay so when a baby can't be fed by
their mother you guys help come up with
a formula that's as close to the
mother's milk as possible have you heard
about baby Fiona at the Cincinnati Zoo
he's a baby hippo who's stolen the
hearts of people all over the country
baby fiona was born six weeks premature
she's a Nile hippo and no other Bay
hippo had been hand raised in North
America and so we needed to put together
a milk formula to be able to feed her to
have her grow so we worked together with
the exotic animal milk repository at the
National Zoo to come up with a formula
to feed baby feeling
so how's Fiona doing now milk is almost
removed from her diet we are very happy
that baby Shona is happy and healthy and
growing very well awesome back to Mike
so what's next
the milk repository has samples from
over a hundred and eighty species of
mammals and that sounds pretty
impressive until you realize that
there's anywhere from five to six
thousand species of mammals so we have
only sampled maybe three percent of the
mammals still only a tiny tip of the
iceburg compared to what we could be
learning
[Music]